olá a todos o anda aqui quem fala é o
dar que sejam muito bem vindos de mais
um vídeo e um estrado de kifayat freires
quadro estamos aqui para julgar a noite
três já tinha jogado esta noite não é
estranho que o fiz há uns dois ou três
dias atrás e consegui chegar até às
cinco da manhã
nessa o extremo por isso eu espero que
desta vez eu consegui passar a noite
envio porque se não vamos ter problemas
não é
vamos lá então pessoal noite três
faculdades é fredes 4 para o pessoal
vamos lá passar esta noite e outro num
quarto de uma das filhas radioshack
ataque forte pode estar aqui fui jantar
o casal se usasse one da equipe do uso
de fred e já tinha 13 aqui meu como é
que é possível um rápido encontro fosse
aqui naquela agora tá aqui a gauchada
porta fechada a porta eu ouvi alguém é
que a menina já está muito confuso
apanhar o force one ambiental e também
pela guarda porque o cara tinha tá
dentro da cozinha eu não posso deixar
que o fox entrou dentro do armário
quanto mais tarde a entrar dentro do
armário melhor é para nós são duas da
manhã treinando aqui ok eu acho que
agora através de itaqui takeo bonin
exatamente igual à que chega também meu
deus está tudo a partir de agora tá tudo
aparecer agora são duas da manhã ainda
meu deus meu deus meu deus aquela chata
jaqueta crítica à crítica calma eu
conheço um pouco o foco está aqui eu
procurava eu voltei agora pra que eu
voltei agora pra que eu possa ir além de
ver outra porta
ok tranquilo
ela é tanto do molho em cima da cama meu
deus tudo está bem não só a itália fica
na outra porta e saí já houve já houve
aqui foi a 14 a minha pessoal agora nós
vamos aguentar
nós vamos aguentar anda camatte que vai
embora por favor meu por favor
tranqüilo porque acho que tá aqui agora
aqui há gato eróticos confirmam isto
bonita que o oponente estudos a porta
agora mesmo que matar xenônio já acaba
tendo moniz eu mantendo moniz andasse na
luz
isso boa sendo que estão tranquilos
enquanto o elenco está tranquilo são
quatro da manhã que vai agüentar
alguém aí o meu como ocultar sangrar o
meu curta essa galera agora o foco é um
símbolo disso aquela faixa a faixa dei
mantenho-a porta fechada mantenha porta
fechada
agora sair o foco da anac além do eu em
tu o filho da mãe toma no armário
a faixa foi a quarta seguida meu deus 15
da manhã coisa com filho anda ana está
aqui ainda está aqui dentro ainda fica
impulso por favor fiquem bush
isso porque não cair precisa estar
pronta agora tática nakheel sair aqui o
meu deus eu todo suado você e eu tudo
errado no azul se ganha por favor passa
por acções da manhã puxa eu tenho que
fazer agora é após o ataque
meu deus curso já cheguei a cair no chão
e logo aí te eu quem o fox watching
antiga fred não sair do conseg tipo
qualquer coisa tanto né não sabe o que
tem que fazer aqui não é não lembro do
vista essa idéia do outro lado tem um
charme e coisas é porque então ok tá que
o fred já que o menino com bush onde
está o teu plus
o meu é o bonin aquilo não parece o
homem é uma armadilha para o dedo foi
como disse alguém escolhido eu vi alguém
escolhido atrás do carro que é quintal e
alguém escondido atrás do carro
bom eu vou porque então
aqui uma menina a menina passou a
contigo ela falou muito sucesso entre o
santo que está a dizer que isto é o que
puxa eu posso apanhar isso for esta o
porto encara do fred vou encontrar um
rato acionária que nem era tá usando
balão ou é melhor tu vais parar a festa
antônio a gente está a ir pra festa ok
toda a gente quem eu acho que o único e
que nem a espera tem sido é o teu
aniversário
o empresário faz fãs o cachê casos que
casa tem cuidado porque a foto estava
posta câmara filho da mãe que o foco
estava a fazer basta que ama alguém usar
uma máscara esse não é o foco se amanhã
é um outro dia aqui não é o foco
original está alguém usar uma máscara do
fox
então é isso só vamos ficar por aqui com
isso espero que vocês tenham gostado se
quiserem ver a noite quatro aqui no
canal deixa mostrar que é favorito e
pronto e é isso fiquem bem e até a
próxima